e
e e
I got figure fig I got to figure out my
buttons it be 1 o'clock we'll open the
meeting and the chancellor of U UNH um
is joining us right now please introduce
yourselves good afternoon thank you Mr
chair and members of the committee for
the record my name is Katherine
preventure I serve as the chancellor of
our state's University system and my
name is Lauren Banker I serve as the
senior director of government relations
for the University system
please so um thank you so much for um a
lotting an hour of your time this
afternoon so that um give you an
orientation about the university system
I'm going to apologize and advance to
those of you on the education funding
committee because you will hear um some
repetitive information that you heard at
that committee I will say though
comments from members of that committee
informed some changes within um this
presentation and I'll Point those out as
we go
through so for those of you on slide one
for the oh I guess it's slide
two this may sound basic information but
if you're not familiar the university
system is made up of three institutions
the University of New Hampshire Kean
State College pulou State University in
uh this past fall we had a total of
enrollment of 23,000 students 8 3% of
those are undergraduates about
19,000 um UNH makes up 69% of that total
enrollment with Keen at 14 and Plymouth
at 17 our total operating expenses in
fiscal year 24 were $928 million about
20% of that is research primarily
Federal research and the research
Enterprise at the University of New
Hampshire has grown 75 % since fiscal n
fiscal year 19 um UNH is only one of 146
universities in the country that's
delegate uh uh classified as an R1
institution in the Carnegie Carnegie
classification which means it's it's
high
research on the next slide slide three
um provide some information hopefully to
um leave you with what a tremendous
asset the university system and frankly
the community college system also are to
the state um in delivering public higher
education to the citizenry we um at the
University system graduate about
3,000 folks well 3,000 folks enter the
New Hampshire Workforce every year and
I'll point out that there's a difference
between the 3,000 in this deck and the
2,000 you heard at the education funding
committee
because um in in thinking through the
impact we really need to in include
graduate and above
um um folks that are entering the
workforce so the 2,000 that I had in the
deck uh at when we last met was only
undergrad this is um graduate bachelor's
and an advanced degrees the university
system has a $3.7 billion economic
impact um on the state and we work with
thousands of businesses across the state
on
internships um businesses are engaged to
inform curriculum with faculty to think
about the future needs maybe not we we
can't pivot quite as quickly as the
community college system can but we work
with businesses to think about what's
the long-term need in our state for
Workforce um the um you're probably
likely aware of the Cooperative
Extension that's a un through UNH it has
reach across the entire state in so many
areas and and Plymouth State and Keen
State also very deeply embedded in the
regions um in the Mano region the Lakes
Region North Country the next slide and
this was this came up when we met with
education funding committee this this is
a slide that my board's education
Excellence committee reviews at each
meeting it's a state in agenda item and
um we look at the top occupations
according to New Hamshire Employment
Security over a 10-year period and we
align those occupations with making sure
that our institutions C have those
degrees and so that's what you'll see on
The Bachelor front and the Masters and
the doctorate the top occupations
according to Employment Security and
where are institu tion programming lines
up with
those this this next slide on slide six
also was
um was asked at the education um funding
committee and it relates to New
Hampshire resident students and
nonresident students and how those
graduates impact our Workforce I
mentioned about 3,00 about 3,000 of our
graduates enter the New Hampshire
Workforce each year about 80% of our New
Hampshire resident graduates stay and
work in the state about 20% of our
non-resident students stay and work in
the state and that is based on we have
an agreement with again Employment
Security no Hampshire employment
security and we share data so that we
can see periodically whether or not our
students are working in the state and
it's it's not student specific that
because of privacy
concerns do you mind taking questions
the middle all not at all repres thank
you Mr chair and thank you for being
here and for taking questions I'll try
to hold most of my questions to the end
to allow the flow to go on but just
looking at what's written down versus
what you said I'm a bit confused
confused because what I wrote in my
notes when I was listening to you was
that 80% of the New Hampshire students
stay in the state and 20% of the out of
state students stay in the state the
bottom says that out of the people Who's
Who start working in New Hampshire 80%
were living in New Hampshire and 20%
were non-resident you know there is a
slight difference between those two
numbers you don't need to tell me right
now which is which but if you could
maybe clarify at a later point cuz if
the numbers of students that come in are
equal there wouldn't be any difference
but if we have you know more of a Kind
coming in the percentages would skew I
don't want to go too deeply into the
weeds right now I will follow up with
you later if you'd like me to clarify a
bit more that sounds great thanks
representative so on slide seven where
where does the state investment go in
fiscal 25 uh the state invested $95
million in the University
system about $81 million of that
95 buys down instate New Hampshire
resident instate tuition and about 14
million is allocated to statutory
programs such as Cooperative Extension
agricultural experiment station this is
another place
where it's about
$7,300 per new Hampshire student this
fiscal year is the state subsidy that 81
million now when you when I met with you
at education funding I had a number of
6,900 in there but the more I thought
about it the
6900 is based on headcount the number of
actual bodies where I think full-time
equivalent is a better measure
to think about the state subsidy and
because this includes graduate
students um AR undergraduate students
for the most part is are
full-time students except uh the College
of professional studies the former
granted State College um that being said
again it's
$7,300 per New Hampshire student is the
the state
subsidy the other uh piece that's not
included uded in this 95 million that
the university system funds on its own
are the um National Guard tuition
waivers the statutory program and to a
much lesser extent there's a foster
child tuition waiver as well and that
approximates about a 2 half million
dollar per year for National Garden and
those
programs on slide eight again this comes
out of conversations with the education
funding committee
so $95 million appropriation about 14
million of that is for our statutory
programs and that breaks down to the
well it's seven I had 7,300 on the prior
slide
7257 right per
student New
Hampshire net tuition not fees but and
this is on average New Hampshire
students net tuition that they pay is
about
$7,000 so if we add the state subsidy
with the net tuition dollars paid by a
New Hampshire student we come up with
14,300 the
net tuition paid by non-resident
students is
16,600 again all on average so we have a
differential there right of
$2,300 so there's
more Revenue if you will and it's not a
surprise with non-resident students what
is your published tuition right the
published tuition rate for um UNH is I
knew you were going to ask that so I
brought all of this with me the at UNH
it's
15,500 for a New Hampshire resident and
36,700 for an outof State
resident and again that's and that makes
sense when we look at the state is
picking up about half the
cost the state's investment is funding
half the
cost of a New Hampshire student that's
what the investment is funding and the
KE in Plymouth State yes yes so at
Plymouth the resident tuition is 11,870
and non-resident is 22,810
and at
keen
11,754 and out of state is
23810 and I have a slide coming in a
little bit will show
you how our tuition both instate and out
of state Stacks up against some other
New England public
peers it's the next one
yep before you go on and what would
housing cost be typically for okay an on
campus
housing housing for a double room at UNH
is
8536 and for a meal plan
5100 you one more time um would it would
it be helpful if I
broke this down for you and sent it to
you on one document with housing and
fees and sure I'm happy to do that if
it's helpful sure
okay so um on slide nine the this shows
for UNH Plymouth and
Kean how tuition instate tuition has
grown since on a percentage basis since
fiscal 20 in each at each of those
institutions so you'll see
Yukon has increased its tuition
22% in
state um now you'll see UNH Plymouth and
keen and again because of St um
increased State support we've held been
able to hold tuition flat um over this
period now unfortunately you will see
that even though we've been holding
tuition flat I Plymouth and Kean are
still this is tuition and fees right
tuition so what's included in fees oh
um Recreation fees athletic fees um you
could have student organization fees and
and when the board sets those fees it's
with student input there's a process on
all of the campuses where student
organizations Student Government meet
with um leaders on the campus to talk
about what those fees should be so it is
um but they're but they're not
insignificant that's why we include them
with um here with tuition and fees so
again Plymouth and
Kean highest instate tuition of it of
these peers other New England Regional
publics and but
Yukon you UNH no longer has the
distinction of having the highest
tuition and fees around Yukon now has
that
distinction can you explain what those
there's obviously three different
categories of college institutions there
what is the distinction that's being
made between the three charts so um we
often
um get Pete right met have a set of
peers so you'll see unh's peers are all
the flagships in New England which are
biggest competitors where Western
Connecticut Westfield Framingham those
are State um universities smaller
regional state universities in
Massachusetts Connecticut and so that
would be a p Plymouth pier and
um Keen State again smaller maybe more
liberal arts focused public in other New
England
States
Representative thank you Mr chair thank
you again
um we were talking about you know the
fact that pretty much half of our
tuition base tuition is covered by the
state and therefore is not meaningful to
the student themselves it's the
taxpayers that shoulder the burden do
the other universities that you compare
you AG with have similar programs and
would you have a comparison of what the
C to the student are rather than the
revenues of the University um not
necessarily on the spot but yeah yes
because I understand that right now we
are looking at your Revenue right now
from all sources but it may also be
meaningful to understand the cost that
the student sees when they you know come
and join so the well I will say that
um so these are the ER prices right of
instate tuition instate tuition and fees
um I'm not I don't believe we're going
to have readily ready access to the
discounting that that the other states
um are doing in relation to
to I don't think that's available um I
will
say that our surrounding states though
do invest more heavily in public higher
ed than than New Hampshire does but um
well maybe Vermont might be a tie with
us um
so I would guess I shouldn't this is
dangerous I shouldn't guess
[Music]
um I'm I'm going to guess that many of
these comparator institutions
the cost to
deliver the education is likely higher
than than um at the University system
I'm just going to guess that because
they
have much more State
support and their tuition and fees
aren't I mean they're they're lower than
ours on Plymouth and Kean but not
significantly but that's a guess
similarly on the next slide uh we did
the same thing for out of state tuition
in fees and um we have not kept out of
state tuition and fees flat um we've
been increasing out of state tuition and
fees about 2 and a half% per year um and
you'll see that so
so the tuition and fees for out of state
for UNH Plymouth and Keen have
been pretty much um comparable with
their
peers except um Connecticut has been
having some um significant changes with
its tuition at at its Regional campuses
but again Plymouth and
Kean are highest sticker prices for um
tuition and fees amongst its
peers so on slide 11 not
withstanding all of that um because the
university system with um State support
has kept tuition flat for I think this
is our fifth year running um and at the
same time increased financial aid for
New Hampshire students the net tuition
and fees for our New Hampshire students
has actually dropped since 2020 from
from 10,500 to 9,800 and again that's
tuition and fees
on the next slide um for the first time
since
2013 our New Hampshire enrollment
increased this fall and
um I I like to think it's because of
keeping tuition
um holding tuition um and the
competition is getting very very stiff
right across New England with well the
next slide will show
you so we our enrollment has has fallen
14% since fiscal
and much of it is because of the
demographics there are fewer fewer
students there are fewer high school
students I'm sure you um are aware of
that with working with
K12 but it's not just New Hampshire I
mean New Hampshire is um I
think feeling it um more deeply than our
surrounding New England states but it's
the fact in all our surrounding
states the demographics there are fewer
young people so the competition is
heating up States want to keep their
young talent in state and so um
so you know we we could lose Mar we have
lost market share as as other states
double down and and um try to keep their
students in state that being said
projections show that it's going to get
worse so on slide 13 you'll see and this
is a um Nathan Gro he's a he's a faculty
member I think maybe in Connecticut who
does the these projections for public uh
College goers and we haven't hit the
bottom the the pipe P line continues to
shrink so before you move on but can you
explain what happens after
29 well you'll see they the numbers well
they go back up they start to tick up I
I get yes I can read the graph why a
births so what you're saying is the
birth rates are improving now they
improve well right yeah good news
so what are we doing about
it we
um we need to think boldly and act and I
will say
it's it's not just about the health of
the University system it's about the
ensuring we can deliver on our mission
and be a significant driver of a high
quality Workforce into the future I was
at a business R participated in a
business r round table last week and um
it's obvious that workfor you know
Workforce housing Child Care those are
the three big issues that that our state
is tackling and and um so as the as the
number of young people
declines um we need to continue to make
sure we can deliver on our mission for
Workforce and Innovation and things like
that for the future of the state that
being said so
over a 5-year period when inflation Rose
23% our employee comp increased
2% I'm going to put a qualifier in that
non-grant compensation I don't include
grants because I told you that the the
grant the research portfolio increased
75% over a 5-year period so that you
have more employees there so I take out
the grants and um we've had had we've
reduced our full-time employees by
5.4% and our parttime employees by 19%
since since
2019 we've reduced our employer
contributions for retirement we are not
members of the New Hampshire retirement
system the university system is a
separate 501c3 so we're not considered
state employees we're not um in the
retirement system uh we we've reduced
our medical plan benefits increasing
employee
premiums we are selling and demolishing
buildings we have fewer students
we can have a smaller footprint we're
exiting least spaces actually one of the
least spaces we are exiting is the
office my the system office here in
conquer and we are moving to New
Hampshire Technical Institute so we're
Chancellor Rubenstein found a little
building near his building and we're
we're moving down there in the June time
frame and at the same time we are
investing in new
technology we went live on December 21st
with uh workday a new enterprise
resource
planning um system
infrastructure um we had been on what's
called Banner very common in highered
for 30 years and it was not going to
meet our needs for the future so it's um
it's a little slowo still
um but but so far so
good um excuse me we have the university
system has many many Partnerships across
the state um a significant partnership
with community college
system we um the two systems recently
announced a 100 Pathways have been
developed so that community college
system
graduates can seamlessly transfer to the
university system and that was a lot of
really hard collaborative work between
faculty and staff with the community
college system and the university system
to have those Pathways so if you you
know if you're a student entering the
community college system and you know
where you you're headed there are
advisors available and you'll know what
your pathway is and we have a direct
admit program so if you meet eligibility
requirements you have a 25 at
UNH you're automatically admitted so um
and and there's a lot going on in that
space and I mentioned there are a lot of
administrative collaborations between
the two systems as well um so we have I
mentioned earlier Partnerships with
businesses across the state um strong
internship Partnerships and we're always
striving to do more with that we know
that out of state students are twice as
likely to stay and work here in New
Hampshire if they've participated in an
internship so um again really building
those relationships with businesses
across the state um UNH was the
inaugural higher ed member of the New
Hampshire Life Sciences Association I'm
not sure if you've been um involved with
with um that Association but they're
really up and coming with it's it's
amazing the the life sciences businesses
that are here in New Hampshire and that
are moving to New Hampshire um and so so
we we
are very much involved with actually the
director of New Hampshire Life Sciences
was on that the business Round Table I
participated in last
week
and the the other part of the our
mission is is um Innovation we think
about the future and was at a hearing
not too long ago in ch can Rubenstein
mentioned something about you know who
would have thought espec certainly not
when I was in college that you'd have a
need for for skills to 3D print
kidneys right so we in thinking about
the future um it's it's so important to
innovate and that's really part of what
the research Enterprise is as well but
it's also really partnering with
business um the John Olen Advanced
manufacturing center if you if you've
ever if you haven't heard of it or you
ever want to take a tour it's it's quite
a remarkable facility um over at UNH and
um high school students Community
College any students um can get hands-on
experience
with the this Advanced manufacturing
equipment there are businesses that are
collocated there um and again that's
it's part of thinking about innovation
the
um the other I I don't I'm not sure if
you're aware so in the southwest part of
our state over in the manad region the
the global
leader in Diamond turning equipment
manufacturing there are about five or
six companies in the southwest corner of
our state they lead the globe on making
this precision diamond turning
equipment um and and those six companies
employ over a thousand people so Keen
state is the only four-year college that
americom the American Center for Optics
manufacturing has chosen to partner with
they partnered with other community
colleges in the country um and Mark uh
boomgarden the CEO of more nanotech was
on that round table last week and they
have partnered with Keen State on
building curriculum and equipping a lab
on the campus again to help with that
Pipeline and that
Workforce and um you know in the theme
of meeting our students where they are
Pou State um recently received approval
from Nei Nei is the acronym for the New
England accrediting body of all colleges
and universities here in New
England and um Plymouth applied for um
five programs to have three-year
bachelor's degrees and were recently
approved and they hope to start those
next fall so business administration
cyber security Outdoor Adventure lead
leadership police studies and
Robotics um to to again students who
want
to complete at a faster Pace maybe at a
lower cost it will be a a three-year
bachelor's
degree I am happy to take any questions
representative Dy no it's tough I can't
remember my name either I have to say as
a former manufacturing individual who
owned a manufacturing facility worldwide
I can't tell you how happy I am to hear
you saying that you're giving these
programs to
students cons conis you know their their
curriculum so that they can get out and
get into the businesses sooner because I
found in all of my time here in the
United here in New Hampshire
manufacturing lacked people coming into
their facilities people were moving out
and going other places because they
could do better and I think that working
on the curriculum like you're doing now
and making a their degree shorter time
and focusing on this with other
manufacturing facilities or any business
for that matter is spot on
thank you Mr chair that's uh one
question that I actually held up not to
interrupt the presentation I'm
developing my ability to not ask all the
time um on slide two you are mentioning
the one 188 millions that you are
spending in direct research direct
research spend I was curious if you
could provide me now or later with a
split between how much of that is
federal funding grants and what not and
how much is State funding and obviously
you mention here is direct expenditures
I would also be interested in a direct
versus indirect you know split whenever
time allows those are not the exact
numbers I'm expecting you to have right
now but if you could follow up 100%
absolutely thank you yes I I can tell
you though I think
so um the
indirect is another 34 million last
year and we'll get the the breakout
almost all of it is FAL but we will
definitely get the breakout for you
Waller uh thank you chairman uh thank
you uh my friend uh I'm not surprised
that uh having watched these
presentations from several of your
predecessors that chers is much more
thorough and much more given to the
numbers which given your background in
finances giving you that Advantage I'm
wondering on page
11 what enabled you
um what caused there to be le less net
tuition
uh what were enable you to get it
reduced so so
um this is average per student so the
price didn't go up yeah but you've got
more help but there's more financial
aid so it could be from the financial
aid could be from institutional sources
it I I'll give you another example um
annual you'll be very familiar with this
the college savings
tuition um
529s yes but representative wer and I
sit on the uh advisory commission and we
flipped that y two or three years ago so
that more dollars are going directly to
the institutions we also
um I think it was before 2020 but um the
university system now has the granite
guarantee program where needy New
Hampshire students pel eligible
students um will cover their
tuition but it's a last dollar
scholarship so as annual scholarships
from the 529 increase right that can
fill some of that Gap as well um so it's
from a number of sources philanthropic
sources institutional
sources um but more financial aid per
student yep has been
awarded over that fiveyear time foure
time period has the endowment
grown the endowment has
grown
um well we've
had some good
returns um um
philanthropy yes it's growing but I
think that that the um the returns that
we've enjoyed have
helped with grow the endowment as well
thank
you representative Murray got it got it
thank you so much chairman
er a couple things that maybe string
together um around the faculty reduction
um and the staff reduction um I assume
can you speak a little bit to how much
that people who are leaving as opposed
to people who are retiring and if that
is tied to any programs that have been
reduced as well courses that students
are missing and if I can just go a
little bit further before I carry on
with some of this others how you
perceive that um impacting quality of
Education um just as an aside one of the
things that if you haven't been to the
Olsson Center it is fabulous I was blown
away that they're 3D producing live
Coral I don't even know how
I don't even know how that makes sense
to me and that they're also doing these
giant things so you can do onsite
repairs for submarines and just from the
little Coral to these it's a remarkable
Center so if you have a chance to visit
it it's it's a great program but any to
my question can you kind of Link The
Faculty reduction loss of jobs quality
loss of programs and a little narrative
around that thank you um so I would I
will argue that we're there's not a loss
of quality um as we have fewer
students um we don't need as many staff
and
faculty um the
and actually it's not it's not unusual
to end a program or start a new program
based on
need
um so in 20
2020 I think it was in the middle of
covid um the university system invested
in an early retirement program because
we knew this was coming this isn't a
secret
it's these folks were born 18 years ago
or 19 years ago so it was it was um a
strategic move the
the many more took the early retirement
program than we had estimated would take
it so we did have to backfill I think
almost 500 people took advantage of that
early retirement program so we did have
to backfill some some of those positions
um but I would say no loss of quality um
we have you know the
highest graduation rate of any New
England public and and pride ourselves
on on that we have very high retention
rates um we could always do better but
the most expensive college degree is the
one you don't finish so it's important
to to everyone across the university
system
to support our students and retain them
and and graduate timely so and
and representative honestly as we look
forward we're going to have to make
additional reductions
because as enrollment
declines we can't stand still
and because of the market competition I
spoke of
earlier the market won't bear big price
increases so it's not well enrollment is
declining so we'll just increase tuition
6% well no because that's going to
impact our ability to attract students
so um High ired is it's it's a it's a
tough gig it's a good thing the mission
second to not that's what I say to my
folks follow up thank you uh my other
question you've worked you and with the
community college system have worked
really hard to make a seamless thing get
from one end to the other and however
you know a way that helps students do
that when you talk about the how your
tuition has been reduced over the years
the cost of students is that reflective
of some students starting in the
community college system which is less
expensive before they get to the UNH
system um and is there can you just
speak if it makes sense to to speak to
the difference between the students cost
if they start in the community college
system and go through as opposed to if
they start at the University system and
go
through so let me try to answer the
first part of your question
first no I do not think
our Revenue has been detrimentally
impacted by closer Partnerships with the
community college
system I like to think that maybe we'll
attract students that might not have
otherwise tried to to go on to a
bachelor's
degree um
so but the second part of your question
I'm sorry I've already forgotten well
fortunately I can remember part of it
there but thank you the way you framed
that I like the way that you framed the
first because I wasn't suggesting it
that um there was any detriment at all
but that it's an a detriment to the
university more that there's an
advantage to the students being able to
go to go through those paths um which
the way you answer the question I think
it sort of makes the other part of my
question kind of irrelevant um so I'll
save you on that one um I had one other
question if I could how's the rink can
you give us a narrative about the rink
ask that too thank you so so um it's in
design
phase I think it's coming to my board
for final
approval it's a it's a sizable project
so it needs board
approval I think it's coming in February
or March so um it's in design they're I
will say you know they're they're
working on making sure that we have the
funding
available um the C construction costs
continue to
increase so um and and so yes it's I
don't know what the estimated completion
date is but it's about ready to come to
the board for approval in the next month
or two I have one more followup maining
theak go ahead thank you again um you
have a partnership with the music hall
in Portsmith for the so-called Arena
concerts and any of those people who
perform there I've never heard of at
this point in my life um but can you
speak to how that partnership is a good
partnership how it's working with the
Music Hall um and how that might pertain
to revenue to the
university
the I can get I'll have to get more
specifics on the partnership and how it
came about but in the in the theme of we
are trying to leverage all of our assets
every way we can um again we have it's
it's an investment it's an asset so
um the the Music Hall is one is one part
of
that thank you yeah no problem
others yes sir representative
papichi thank you Mr chairman um as you
know I was talking to you when you had
the previous presentation about um the
potential correlation between some of
the drops in student tuition and the uh
you know lesser number of students that
may be attending which may allow you to
allocate a bit more towards the tuition
Aid just to make sure we all understand
that could we maybe have like the last
for the last 10 years the total amount
spend the university to buy down in
state tuition and the number of students
that impacted because this will kind of
clarify All Those Questions around that
particular area um just to make sure
that I'm I'm getting this right you
maybe a trend of the are we looking for
the state appropriation per New
Hampshire student over a 10 year period
no no no we we can do that without
asking you that directly right because
we have all those numbers but right now
there is a certain amount of the state
appropriation that the university is
using to buy down the instate tuition I
just would like that number and the
number of students that it was allocated
to because that's how you got your
$7,300 or what 7257 on the next slide
right so I'd like that for the last 10
years to just see how it moved around
and maybe shed some light into you know
what moves it a little and of course any
color that you have around why the
changes would help us you know instead
of guessing we' know exactly what you
thought at the time but it doesn't have
to be a big thing just just to clarify
that question happy too thank you so
much and can I request that you send all
your answers or questions to Mr landan
and so he can then distribute them to
the whole of course Committee of course
thank you no no private date
I representative hacken Phillips thank
you chair um thank you Kathy and Lauren
for being here today um since we are
finance division 2 and we are thinking
about the upcoming budget budget cycle
I'm just wondering if you have um kind
of a preview for us about possibly any
concerns or drivers that you see as you
head deeper into the cycle um as as
we're you know moving from the
governor's phase of the budget to into
the house phase you know you know kind
of anything on the horizon that you're
worried about or um that we should be
prepared to hear about in the
future uh thank you representative um
I'm I'm deeply
worried um I don't
know I'm not sure where the governor's
budget um what what the governor will
propose in her
budget uh
the go uh former governor sonunu had
um asked that we um budget for a 4% cut
which took us to $91 A5
million and we model that out um we do
long-term Financial modeling at least
once a year so we had modeled that out
for my board strategic retreat in
September and it that will be painful
but we modeled it out and we're working
on how we're going to
think about the future um since then
we're hearing it's it could be much
worse than a 4% cut again I'm not I I
don't know yet what that looks like um
but that will require very that will
require deep Cuts we we're
um I I I pride myself in the University
system on we have a balanced budget we
don't run in the red but we don't run
big black
either um and so we'll we'll and and I
fully expect my board isn't going to say
well okay the
state had a we had a cut and so we're
going to run in the red we're going to
have to figure that out so frankly I'm
I'm quite
concerned then I'll ask you a question
uh this it goes back to the historical
so in the last hb2 the state provided $3
million and UNH balance matched it with3
million dollar for PSNH and U Kean could
you uh PSU I mean and Kean Could you um
tell us what what happened with that
money what was for the the
um it gave Plymouth and
Kean uh a little bit of cushion to act
to get the budget their budgets
balanced and it worked so Kean had been
running in the red
for six or seven
years and um they're breaking even now
even without the additional dollars in
fiscal 25 it provided that
cushion um so and you know I would I
would as I think about the upcoming by
enum if there was any opportunity for a
step down of a reduction we know we have
to
act with urgency and boldly but if there
was any kind of a step down that might
help give us some Runway the fiscal year
starts in five
months so um anyway that that one
time kicker if you will for Plymouth and
Kean did what it was intended Ed to do
give them some Runway to make changes
to to get to a a better
spot and can I ask that you um provide
us with a more detailed version of your
budget your overall budget
certainly thank
you any other
questions anything else you want to just
I usually like to end with just could
you I want to make sure I we have down
everything we want you want us to bring
back to you so Lauren if you could run
just so we're we're not missing anything
these are my notes to send to Mr Lander
again um a breakdown of housing fees
tuition out of state and in state for
each
institution
um uh information about musical
Partnerships with UNH I think we talked
about that briefly uh last 10 years
total number uh buy down that the um
between usnh and New Hampshire State
dollars including student count too you
wanted to and then detailed version of
uh the usnh
budget what I
got am I missing
anything there one more representative
Pap papichi there was that um early
request for U the 188 millions in direct
research spend the split between federal
and state funding and ideally both in
direct and indirect cost splits the same
split the same way
um we were able to get the 34 million
for the total indirect but a breakdown
would be very appreciated thank you
certainly and and we'll F I'll follow up
with you offline on the the comment on
the bottom of SL slide six just so we're
I
don't okay right
okay everybody all set no more
questions no more comments just the last
slide has contact information for Lauren
and myself we're always available email
call text um and we'll try to get
whatever
information um you'd find helpful thank
you very much for all the presentations
You' been giving throughout the last few
weeks they been wonderful I appreciate
it thank you very much
let's at least give um represented
Philips hack and Phillips a break
anybody anybody else wants a break
everybody could take a
stretch
e
e e
turn my mic on let be slight me before 2
o'clock let's open
the community college system of New
Hampshire and I'll ask you to both in
introduce
yourselves thank thank you very much
representative her and members of the
committee Mark Rubenstein Chancellor of
the community college
system good afternoon Shannon Reed
director of government Affairs for the
community college system and briefly I
just want to explain the the two
materials you have before you the slide
deck is you'll notice dated November of
2024 this was our presentation to the
governor's panel and since it was
already part of the LBA budget documents
we thought just in the interest of not
presenting you with too many very
similar versions of the same thing we
would we would go with this but we can
certainly talk through anything that has
um that has been asked or has come up in
conversations since uh since last
November and then the second the second
document just the two-pager um is very
specific to one area of our work which
is um Workforce training and
Partnerships with businesses and even
more specifically a result of specific
funding that the legislature included in
the community college systems budget
last time around that we want to show
you impacts to date and and make a case
we hope for continuation
funding thank thank you um I'm going to
spend most of my time on just the second
page of the handout and so it'll save
you a little bit of page flipping just
for background our our mission and you
don't have to look at this it's on the
fourth slide it had succinctly stated
it's to create opportunities for
students in New Hampshire that align
with the needs of the
state and to do it in ways that are
accessible and affordable and deliver
high quality programs simply put so
referring back to the second slide a
couple of things that you'll discern
from that is a Statewide map the
community college system of New
Hampshire has a presence in every region
of the state by Design and it's
complemented by the fact that now about
a third of our well 30% of our core
instruction is delivered virtually it's
online so in theory you would say place
doesn't matter but Place actually does
matter a great deal and a lot of what we
do is Hands-On on and directly engaging
students in every corner of New
Hampshire in ways that align with the
opportunities that exist in those
communities as you'll see 93% of our
students are from New Hampshire and i'
I've said before in similar settings
that if you think about that other 7%
significantly the Upper Valley near
Vermont Coastal main if you will or in
Inland main I I guess it would be uh
whether the Sea Coast or the North
Country and and even the northern edge
of Massachusetts that spills into where
NASA is we are serving primarily New
Hampshire residents and the New
Hampshire
Workforce and our efforts to serve that
population are
lifelong we spent a little time earlier
as you were hearing from Chancellor
prenter talking about demographics and I
fully understand the concern we see
fewer students coming out of New
Hampshire High Schools too but if you
accept the premise that learning is
lifelong and that students over the
course of a 50 or 60e working life will
have to find ways to remain current and
engaged then we need to be able to serve
students throughout that
span and so you'll see on this first uh
Slide the ways in which we do that early
college serving students whether in
their high schools on our campuses or
online is a significant part of the work
that we do last year we served over
10,000 students here in New Hampshire
they pursued 54,000 credits their
ability to do that was largely free of
cost well I shouldn't say that free of
charge to the students and their
families because the legislature
invested $2.5 million in the banum each
year the bium for us to underwrite the
cost of doing that those 54,000 credits
if those students had paid at our
tuition and fee rates would have caus
cost about 1 $13
million so the return on investment for
$2.5 million from the
state formidable return on investment I
don't know where else you find that but
that's just the financial piece the real
impact for students and
families represent Murray had asked the
question earlier about the cost of an
education if you have a student who
hasn't just taken one or two courses but
has completed a semester or a year or an
associate degree through this program
that's a year of tuition and fees living
expenses that's a year of debt that they
don't have to take out that's a year
sooner into the workforce beginning to
see a return on that investment both for
the student and family but also for the
state so that that investment the state
has made we think is significant I I
should mention last year that 54,000
credits that's about a 15%
year-over-year increase
and that has been a steady
climb and in the current year although
the pace of growth has slowed with a
with a larger base to work with the in
the fall we saw about an 8% increase
right now in the spring running about
11% ahead of where we were last year so
we expect year-over-year probably
somewhere around 10% probably close to
60,000 credits again going back to the
math the same $2.5 million that the
state has invested for return
significantly above and that $13 million
in tuition and fee savings that I
described is at our tuition rate $ 215
ACC credit $25 enrollment fee you
translate that to a semester at a public
Institution for your institution or at a
private
institution and I'm not suggesting that
every program and every student will
benefit in the same way but the
opportunities are are really Broad and
and impactful for students and families
and and for the state
so those 10,000 students that we serve
through our early college
programs about 40% of our enrollment we
also had between 11, 52,000 students on
our campuses and I I'll use on our
campuses a little bit figuratively as I
said earlier a significant portion of
that is actually occurring
online
and one of the things to understand
about our students that is somewhat
different than the university system is
is who our students are 40% are 25 and
older 2/3 are part-time students the
majority of them are working while
they're in school and school is is part
of their life but not all of their life
and in that regard you we sometimes talk
about 2E and four-year institutions most
of our students are not 2-year and
fouryear students most of our students
are going to be four and five and sixe
students to get the two-year degree
completed and it's not always a linear
uh journey and and going in One
Direction I've shared in previous
hearings one in five of our nursing
students already holds a bachelor's
degree in some other field but they've
come back to see us for an associate
degree in nursing because that's what
they want to do that's what they need to
do and because so many of those students
already anchored in their communities
one of the Returns on investment to the
state in our programs is that those are
students who stay there and two years
ago the I I don't last year's numbers
two years ago the graduating class of
nursing students at White Mountains
community College in Berlin 26 students
22 by graduation already accepted jobs
north of The Notches those are students
who are staying local because their
lives are local their families are local
so the ability to connect students with
opportunities in places that matter to
them and matter to the state is part of
the work I should mention a couple of
other things one about 265 graduates of
our nursing programs last year that's
for the RN program an additional 57 LPN
graduates countless number of licensed
nursing assistants medical assistant and
my colleague Chris Dudley will talk a
little bit more about that shortly um so
again helping to meet a critical need
that the state has and partnering with
uh stakeholders throughout the
communities in New Hampshire to ensure
that we can meet those needs so that's
the second group of students in addition
to the early college students the more
traditional non-traditional students the
Third group that we serve about 2500
students in various Workforce programs
and that can be anything from uh a a
short-term you know four six week
training program uh some of our boot
camps we've got a microelectronics boot
camp de developed in partnership with
BAE systems for very specific work that
they need soldering boot camps welding
boot camps things that are very Hands-On
none of this can really work online um
these are typ speically for working
adults but sometimes younger working
adults who need an opportunity that
doesn't lend itself to two or 3 years of
Education and Training they need a job
today coupled with our apprenticeship
programs where you're earning while
you're learning we have ways to help
students to be in the workforce as
they're gaining the additional skills
and a foundation that allows them to
grow and a lot of these programs even
though it's a short-term program and
it's foundational it becomes the Bedrock
on which they can build uh agree over
time to grow in in various career Fields
so I'm I'm going to uh stop for a moment
and just uh see if there's anything that
I've said that has prompted questions
and if not then I'm going to invite my
colleague Chris Dudley to join me to
speak a little bit more in detail about
the work that she and colleagues do on
the uh career focused Workforce
programs
questions representative papichi
thank you very briefly um I have a
question and a tiny neat picky point but
I'm going to start with a question you
are mentioning that $2.5 million a year
that we provided in the previous budget
saved about $13 million worth of tuition
that you you know our residents would
have paid I'm assuming that 13 million
was saved by the 5 million we paid over
the bayum right no each year each year
each year oh it was question answer a
okay got it and Ely nitpicky on this uh
document the very very first accelerated
welding thing it's quite impossible for
a program with 21 students to have a 97%
completion rate it should be 995 if one
of them failed I agree it's need picky
but I cannot stop myself thank you I I I
I I appreciate your observation sir we
will review the data
it is a good
Segway good afternoon I'm Christine
Dudley the director of Workforce
Development at Manchester Community
College thank you for having me um it's
it's it's wonderful to be here and I I
just want to say that um my mom served
as a state rep and also a state senator
for a number of years so it's nice to be
here and I um appreciate the opportunity
um so to talk a little bit about our
students thank you Chancellor um I'd
like to actually uh talk a little bit
because we do have some of the most
vulnerable students that come to us at
the community college system uh the
barriers that they have to
overcome um even to just come see us to
be interested in a program to change
jobs um they've got some significant
things that they're overcoming and it's
amazing that we've had the opportunity
to support them through some of these um
programs and funding that we've been
able to give them if we take a look
first I I actually would like to look at
uh the backside that talks a little bit
about our students first um 63% of our
students in Workforce Development are 25
years and older so on the on the four
credit side it might be 40% but it's
63% um many of them are coming to us
with um jobs so uh they have families
they have housing concern concerns they
have child care concerns uh all of those
um things are are what we work with them
on so it's not just about their
education but it's also trying to
connect them to our partners um also uh
our students um if you look at the first
bullet point many of them are returning
so though we've had 62 52 enrollments
over two and a half years about 1,00 of
those students are returning so they've
they've come and done multiple classes
with us
um so and also 15% of the work that
we're doing right now is in healthcare
it's a significant amount of what we do
and of that 30% of those are apprentices
so they're people that are taking
advantage of those earn and learn
programs where they can earn a livable
wage while take a training program um to
better support their family or the job
change or whatever it is that they're
going through at that time um so that's
a that's a really important percentage
in terms of the apprenticeship because
it does help to break down some of those
barriers that our audience sees um so th
those are just a few things around um
who our students are and we also work
with employers for customized training
so there's another section of
information around enrollment in classes
that we have with um manufacturers um
some of our school districts um even our
Community Partners um you know State
departments health and human services so
we really support a very wide range of
organizations uh across lots of
different Industries
so um on the front side uh thank you
very much for the the correction we will
look at that data um some of the themes
i' I'd like to point out um we took
about six to nine months to um you know
from the last bium and being awarded the
the uh legislative funding to support
Workforce Development we've been able to
build some new programs expand some new
programs some of the themes are
definitely uh continue to be in
healthcare so as you can see uh EMT
training medical assistant LNA um just
from year uh Academic Year 22 to 23 to
23 24 our LNA programs increased across
the state
38% so we've we've seen some really
significant growth in these areas and
for us to be able to scale and expand
these programs to different areas of the
state that the chancellor talked about
earlier it's so important for our
students the barriers of Transportation
the barriers of um child care it doesn't
oftentimes allow someone to even take a
program if they live in NASA to come to
Manchester so we've really been able to
uh look at the key areas that need
expansion to serve those audiences and
that's been um that scalability that
expansion has been really critical for
us in these high demand Industries um
that we're seeing and that people want
to go into um and some other themes um
you know that have been
supportive that have been supported uh
are in the equipment infrastructure area
I mentioned scaling scaling and
expanding programs um we've also been
able to support our students with some
scholarship funding in some of these
programs where the workforce programs
are not supported by pel so we often
times have someone who is working they
have a full-time job it is not meeting
um the expenses that they need for their
family they would like to switch jobs in
those circumstances it's it's oftentimes
difficult for us to find um an
organization that with the guidelines
that could potentially support that
student um for example we owe a funding
there are some very strict guidelines
oftentimes our students who are changing
jobs may not qualify for that so some of
the scholarship dollars that we've been
able to help our students with have made
a significant impact on their
life and we have some impact statements
at the bottom of the page um from some
of our students unsolicited uh who uh
shared with us just how much programs
that they've been able to take they've
gotten a job have really changed their
lives
so I'll stop there for a
minute questions representative
Murray thank you um couple of questions
oh sorry thank you Mr chair a couple
questions is your mom Dudley no you're
not Dudley Dudley okay no her her name
is inber okay saying Dudley Dudley's a
good old friend
yes um can you
add a few more words around the lack of
public transportation I'm glad you
mentioned that but the do you have a
sense of the number of students who
can't attend classes because of that and
what would public transportation look
like to you in order you know what would
what do it what would it look like to be
successful yeah I think that here in New
Hampshire as we know we we primarily um
are a driving state so just from from
City to City so I think within our
cities our public transportation is very
good so we have a we have a bus that
comes to Manchester Community College so
people that are in our area are able to
access us but if we're looking at a
program that we might have in Manchester
but the person lives in really not not
so far 20 minutes or so nashwa conquered
that person is not able to get to us um
across city lines really um so I think
that it's it's more um about having we
have those supports within our cities
it's when it's right over that City line
that we're really seeing people not be
able to make those travel Arrangements
uh on a consistent basis as well I I
hope that answered all right thank you
um next you mentioned um a lot of your
students are over 25 which is still
pretty darn young frankly it is it is
but um and I know that they're coming in
for Advanced Training or they're you
know just trying to they're working
another job and they're trying to get
another degree can you speak to the
number of people who are that much older
than 25 are people who are facing career
challenges or career changes for a
variety of reasons yes I actually think
I have the demographics with
the just take a look and see where
I believe I have
that
um and I could also send this to you but
we we do have students um uh that are of
varying ages um actually one of our
students in the quotes I think he was 68
changing jobs to a CDL to drive cdlb to
drive the smaller trucks um and so that
is an example of a stu an older student
who is changing jobs uh we've had you
know moms who have large families that
are changing jobs um so I I will look
for the um we do have some data on the
demographics I'm just it's in one of my
packets I'm happy to come back to that
if that's okay okay thank and one more
yes Absolut thank you I know some 68
year olds who shouldn't be driving at
all never mind driving a
truck he's doing well though he is he's
doing very well um can you foresee the
what's the state of pel Grants looking
like
so I that's a very good question um as
of right now it has not been passed to
have Workforce programs short-term
credentialing programs be part of pel um
I'm not sure where that is federally
right now uh but it was not p has not
been passed it was a proposal on the
table um and I believe the last I read
that it it has it's it's still in
waiting so it it would significantly
change um the funding opportunities for
these programs and for these
students if if I may add this issue of
work what's called Workforce P the
short-term programs has been kicking
around in Congress for a long time
and it's one of the places where higher
education is changing as I said the idea
of working adults lifelong Learners
federal financial aid has not kept up
with that change and we've benefited a
good deal from weoa funding Workforce
opportunity Innovation act funding for
specific areas of
opportunity but we still need ways of
supporting students whose lives just
don't lend themselves to the the broader
initiatives I I'll remark also to your
question a moment ago representative
Murray at one level what we can provide
is more anecdote and we know that a lot
of anecdotes are not data but in some
ways the nature of the population that
we serve working adults their lives are
in some ways there there are themes that
you can find but in some ways they are
so unique that they just don't fit into
things when we talk about a program that
serves about a dozen students in EMT
training in the North country that
that's impactful you're not going to get
numbers in the hundreds or the thousands
in almost anything but for the impact of
serving a half a dozen plow drivers to
train train for CDL ahead of a winter in
New Hampshire that's an impact the
ability to train a dozen EMTs so again
our efforts dispersed regionally trying
to be responsive to the very varied
needs of the broad mix of students we
serve is is trying to responsive to
people's lives and and the
communities other
questions thank you not not a question
as much as a comment and thank you Mr
chairman we don't always try to measure
uh stuff you know with the same type of
measures because we do recognize that
sometimes ccsnh is U like microt
targeting a particular n a particular
area and even though the impact
Statewide may be small overall it is a
very significant impact for that area so
I agree with you that it's really hard
to quantify some things but I would like
to just assure you that we are trying to
adjust for that and devaluate you know
measure the value accordingly and even
though sometimes it's kind of hard to
put into overall numbers thank
you well I have a couple of requests um
could you provide a list of the course
available in the Dual and concurrent
enrollment program and this other
program that you were speaking to so
this this essentially a fourth program
you have the original Three there and
your opening slide kind this this is
really elaboration on that third area of
our work okay all right math learning
communities can you provide the annual
reports recent annual reports on those
we can do that
great uh what else I want to ask you
this a great presentation
I was actually able to plan ahead
because you did such a good
job representative F at at the risk of
saying anything after you've said great
presentation uh if if I if I could just
I'll elaborate a little bit more um I if
you were to go past page two in fact go
past Pages 10 and 11 which outline many
of the Partnerships we have with
employers estate to get to Pages 12 and
13 12 is the efficiency budget
we you can see I've marked it up
thoroughly that's your page 12 okay
thank P page 12 is the E efficiency
budget that we submitted and the one
note that I'd want to draw attention to
on that one is that included in that
from the last biannual budget we
received from the legislature $1.25
million each year to support early
childhood education course
and the reason we had made that request
was understanding from our faculty who
teach in that area that often there are
a number of Grant programs to support
early childhood education but they often
have very specific requirements either
hours of employment or which courses are
covered and which are not and what we
had Learned was that many students in
those programs stop when they get to the
chasm that's created by having to pay
for a course that's not covered by the
Grant in part because the wages in that
work don't necessarily justify the
tuition or the debt that a student would
take on by being able to cover those
costs we've been able to help more
students complete those programs and
we've got very good feedback from a lot
of stakeholders telling us that that's
sensible so I want you to know that that
is part of our our base budget when we
think about year-over-year what
distinguishes that because it's almost a
a carve out if you will there are number
of things on page 13 that are part of
our budget current budget from House
Bill two and the rationale for
requesting those was in part to be very
clear about what the return on
investment would be to the state and for
us to be more
accountable you you'll see in there a
request to increase duel and concurrent
enrollment allow us to continue to grow
that program you'll see a request for us
to be able to continue to freeze tuition
as Chancellor preventure remarked we've
had tuition Frozen since
2018 but in fact going back to 2011
tuition has only gone up $5 in total
over what will be 15 years at the end of
this
bium against the backdrop of inflation
you know what that means it's only been
feasible because the state has continued
to invest in Partnership when we started
doing that we
were virtually the most expensive
community college system in the country
we're still probably in the top even
though it's been kept flat but what has
happened is the value of a pel grant has
grown over time so that now a full-time
student in the community college system
and there are some but not a lot the
cost of tuition and basic fees is $7,200
for 30 credits and a pel grant will
cover that so ideally we'd like to be
able to sustain the progress we've made
in affordability but among our
priorities that the highest priority
because of the value that we think it
confers to students and families is that
dual and concurrent enrollment
going back to a question that
representative Murray asked earlier
about the early college and or about the
value s the cost of a full
degree what Chancellor preventure and I
have talked about is that using Pathways
between our two systems but anchoring
them in Early College opportunities
really has the potential both to make
postsecondary education that much more
affordable for New Hampshire but also we
think to help more students find their
way to New Hampshire institutions the
other priority there in addition to math
learning communities which is is
valuable in its own right are the
workforce credential programs those are
the things that director Dudley was
describing so I just want to draw
attention to the specifics of our
priorities in the current
panium so that's specifically this that
those are examples of what this has
funded and and more we are building a
systemwide Core curriculum for automated
Manufacturing and biofabrication which
we think will ultimately be helpful for
the future as Chan preventure described
my my observations my guidance counselor
never told me that I'd be using a 3D
printer to manufacture a pancreas and
had I known that I might have I might
have chosen a different different path
we don't know what the future holds but
we do think that that's an important
industry for the future of New Hampshire
and we think that we should be providing
opportunities across the state so that
Core Curriculum is of the things that
we're working to build so that students
throughout New Hampshire can participate
in that
economy represent h p yeah thank you Mr
chair uh thank you um Chancellor for
taking my question um I'm just wondering
specifically about the Dual and
concurrent program um could you talk a
little bit more about what kind of
students um in their high school years
would take advantage of that program and
then also could you speak about um
like how many credits they're eligible
for under current you know program
requirements and then if you could also
just speak a little bit about the
potential for increasing that I think
there's a bill floating through the
house that would increase those credit
hour
eligibility um requirements so if you
could just elaborate thank
you try and keep all of
this so to to no no To Tot totally fine
the first question about the type of
student yeah originally the intent of
early college was to reach students who
didn't realize that postsecondary
education was a possibility for them and
and I I talking specifically when I say
about post-secondary education not
everything is four-year College not
everything is traditional bachelors and
Beyond but there's a tendency to group
those things what what has happened over
time is that these have become
alternatives to AP courses and honors
courses for highly motivated students
and in some respects although it's still
valuable for a student whose ambition is
to go to a 4-year institution to have
access to these courses but it has
displaced the student who was the
original intent the student who didn't
realize that they were capable of doing
this kind of work so our goal in growing
opportunities is to have more students
for whom postsecondary education is
going to be important one of our
significant programs auto automotive
technicians still requires a degree
increasingly the cars on the roads in
New Hampshire are complex are computer
you know I don't want to say driven but
but are incredibly complex instruments
and require Advanced education so for
students who want to be able to work in
that field postsecondary education will
be meaningful the last year 30% of the
credits for students doing our early
college came through students enrolled
at CTE centers we think we're starting
to reach that group in a way that that
we hadn't fully reached in the past and
we think that's an area of growth and
opportunity although again for any
student for any family given the cost of
Education the opportunity to save the
value of a year a semester a year two
years of college is going to be
meaningful currently the limitation is
two courses per year so in theory a
student in 10th 11th and 12th grade
could complete the equivalent of six
courses at the expense of the state and
students with resources can reach into
their pockets or their parents pockets
and take more the the the goal would be
to grow this I believe though that the
piece of legislation that you've
referenced is actually intended to
clarify a point of confusion we do have
some courses that the course itself is
an eight credit course and it creates a
bit of a distortion in in what the
intent was so I believe the legislation
that representative lad has brought
forward in this session is to clarify
that each of the two courses currently
available to a student is is for credit
course and if I can just add to that
there are actually two bills that are
currently with the house education
funding committee one is that one which
which restricts the use to courses that
are three or four credits and then
there's another bill that would actually
fund the program which at the same level
that we're that we're asking here in
division 2 and I think we just W really
weren't sure of the pathway that
education funding bills would take with
the new committee established but I I
understand it this one will start there
and presumably make its way over
here representative hacken Phils did I
answer all
three thank you I just want to be
sure uh representative muray yeah thank
you again Mr chair can you cycle back to
the successes around the nursing program
um I keep losing my space here uh but
I'm mainly concerned can you just speak
to um their employment status and how
many of them have remained in New
Hampshire and how fluid is How likely
are nurses to move because they're not
necessarily the first um earner they
could be you know this possibly the
second earner um can just be you know
are they do the are they employed is it
a livable wage and do they stay here we
we'll have have to get more solid data
from New Hampshire employment security
but as I shared
earlier M significant number of our
nursing students one in five already has
a bachelor's degree in fact I they tend
to skew older among our students tend to
be stable in the communities so in that
regard these aren't I'm not going to say
none but these aren't necessarily recent
you know younger people who are going to
become travel nurses for instance and
see the world before figuring out where
they want to settle down in many cases
these are folks who work where they live
where their families are and have more
stability I can't say that particularly
in the southern part of the state that
there's not a pull from the labor market
we know there's a 22% wage premium I
believe for nurses in
Massachusetts but there's a lot of
aggravation to have to drive back and
forth to Massachusetts and we we hope
over time that that settles itself out
yeah thank you I'm glad to hear you
elaborate about these are not
necessarily new students but are nurses
who are continuing their careers and are
established in their community and and
if I could point out on slide nine of
the presentation the student The
Graduate in that picture just graduated
from a nursing program at Lakes Region
Community College and you can see him
there with his two sons so this is the
kind of student that that's more likely
to stay in the community where their
children are in school and they have
ties s if I may since we're talking
about Nursing education I never want to
miss the opport say 6 years in a row
nurses in New Hampshire highest
firsttime enlex pass rate in the country
a real tribute to the nursing faculty
across all of our institutions
University system community college
system and others but but the quality of
Education our students receive
translates to the quality of Health Care
that our residents and citizens receive
and I think that's important to
note any else um so two last requests
could you provide a PDF of this and also
could you also provide your more detail
budget the ab program thank you very
much thank you uh yes of course
representative H PHS thank you um I just
wanted to give you an opportunity to
answer the same question I asked of
Kathy before um given that we're the
finance committee and we're thinking
about the upcoming cycle are there any
um concerns on the horizon that you'd
like us to know about in advance of um
receiving that eventual budget from the
governor um
I reading uh the preliminary Revenue
estimates that come out in the last half
of each month you have to be sober by
what the state is facing and we're
sensitive to that obviously we
appreciate the level of support we've
had and it still doesn't stop us from
asking for more because we think there's
a return on investment to the state
we're also keenly aware of competing
pressures that this body will have to
balance and going back to the earlier
discussion about the complex lives of
our students in many cases the other
places where you might choose to invest
will matter to them too so hard choices
for you to make I said I think our
responsibility is to deliver as much
quality in return for the investment you
can find for us thank you
thank you very much thank you
Mickey anything we need to
know um media Jed thank you Mr Lander